There we go, all right guys, welcome to the call, we got one more person that's joining
right now and let me let them in and then we'll get going right away.
Hold on just a second, all right, guys welcome to the call, welcome Craig just joined, maybe.
I'm not really sure, okay, now he's back, let's see.
Let's see what we got here, there's Craig, all right Craig welcome to the call man, good
to have you on, I've got this thing recording, let's jump right into it, I just want to pull
up a couple notes to make sure I don't miss anything and it's gonna make me sign in, hold
on one second guys, I hope it's not making me do the two-step note, we're good, okay.
Just want to make sure we don't miss anything, I've got a few things I wanted to make sure
just to cover really quick and then let's dive into some Q&A, go over anything you guys
want to talk about, I've got a few things I want to cover and let's start off this
Monday morning, I guess it's 7 a.m. for you guys depending on where you're at, all right,
here we are, okay, as long as you guys can hear me let's get started, so guys, Craig
is here, what am I seeing over here, okay, all right guys, March 3rd, we're two months
into the new year, crazy hot times flying, I would highly encourage you guys if you haven't
made a habit of doing this is take the first Monday of every month, Monday, Tuesday and
look at how your month went, did you hit the goals that you set, your revenue goals,
if you didn't hit your revenue goals, hold on, letting people in, there's Frank back
in the house, okay, if you didn't hit your revenue goals, why, did you not do enough
appointments, did you not do enough Zoom calls, if you didn't do enough Zoom calls, why is
that, did you not get enough business owners on the hook, what I'm going to be doing today
in about an hour after this call finishes is I'm going to be going through, got my
goals in my notebook here and I'll be looking at what, you know, where we actually ended
up for the month versus where our goal was to end up and then just course correct, guys,
it's very simple stuff but it's just like if we were trying to go from, just like the
example I always like to use, if our roadmap, if we started in Washington where Paul's at
and we wanted to get to Miami and Miami would be representative of our goal of $20,000 per
month by July 1st or by December 31st, right, you want to take inventory and find out, okay,
it's two months in and we're all the way over in Idaho when we should be down in, I don't
know, Denver, I don't even know where the path would be but okay, that's fine, you guys,
we can still get to Miami but now we got to take a different direction, we've got to speed
it up, we can't take as many breaks, we've got to, you know, maybe increase the speed
that we were going to go by five miles per hour for the next, you know, two months, whatever,
but guys, you have to be taking inventory.
One thing I did not do last year is I set my goals and I just kind of like, just did
my thing.
I didn't check on them, I didn't, you know, audit where we were at and that was a huge
mistake.
This year so far I've done a really good job and at the end of last month I went and I
just took my notebook, looked at my goals, we had our biggest month of the last 12 months
was January and I was like, what do we do right, what do we do wrong and anyway, just
a simple thing, you guys, just take an hour, look at your goals and by the way, if you
don't even have your goals, go watch the, we have a mini course called Map Your Goals
or I think it's called Map Your Goals, go watch that, set your goals.
You guys, what we use, I think I talk about it in the training, but I use this book, Think
and Grow Rich, one of the sections in here, one of the chapters in here talks about basically
goal setting and we use the framework from this book to set your goals, okay, that's
what I like and I think it's chapter, I think it's chapter, what chapter is it, let me just
tell you guys in case you want to check it out.
I think it is chapter, dang, these chapters are a little bit beefy, hold on, hold on,
I think it's chapter seven, I think it's chapter seven, I could be wrong, but anyway, I'm almost
positive it's chapter seven, maybe somebody can back me up there, but anyway, yes, under
organized planning, I think this is the chapter that you're going to want to use.
Anyway, if you guys haven't set your goals, please do that, please do that, it's going
to be huge for you guys, okay.
Other thing I want to say really quick and then we'll get into Q&A, a couple weeks ago
I shared a link inside of the group, inside of the school community and it was a link
to a book called The Slide Edge, okay, free link, free PDF and I just said to you guys
this book, I think I said this book will change your life and I want you guys to know that
I started this book around, this is my fifth time reading it, fourth or fifth time reading
it, I started this book around the last week of January, I just finished it on Saturday,
okay, I was on the treadmill, finished the last pages, guys, this book, it's such a simple
book, it's such an easy read, but I promise you and it's not an affiliate link, it's
none of that, it will change your life.
If you just read the book 10 pages a day, you read the book, you do the actions, I've
recommended my little, I've recommended everybody in digital landlords to read it, I've personally
asked my little brother Porter to read it, which by the way, I think he's like a fourth
the way through, I bought multiple copies for people, it is a phenomenal book, if you
feel like you're stuck in a rut, if you feel like you can't quite get that momentum, if
you feel like you're just, you're right there on the cusp that you can't get it, go read
this book, okay, slide edge 10 pages a day, it'll freaking change your life and I'm telling
you that again, I have no, I'm not getting paid to say that, whatever, okay, but guys,
what this book's done for me, it's just allowed me, it just helped me to have a number one
realize that it's literally this game is about doing all these little things correctly and
doing them again and again and again and again and when you start doing the little things
in one area, it bleeds to another area and it bleeds to another area and it bleeds to
another area and that's in the negative and in the positive, okay, so let me just give
you an example, last year, something that I was not very good at is I was very lazy
about when I would travel, okay, I would look at the, I would go to book my travel
and I would travel any day of the week, sometimes it was a Monday, sometimes it was a Wednesday,
sometimes it was a Friday, sometimes it was a Sunday and what would happen is sometimes
I would leave Dubai, let's say like on a Monday or a Tuesday, I miss the whole Tuesday, I
get in, I miss the whole Wednesday, I'm jet lagged for Thursday and then I want to spend
time with my kids on Friday, I was missing entire weeks because of just that little decision
of not even thinking about when should I book my flight.
This year, I'm very intentional about, hey, I'm not missing work days, I'll travel on
the weekends and I'll miss my weekends, I'll sacrifice going out on the weekend so I can
travel, I can get to my spot, get set up, get rested and get ready to go.
So I was coming to London, I think I already said that, I came to London and I was trying
to figure out when should I go, when should I go, when should I go and I literally made
the decision to come here on a Friday, like a Friday afternoon so I could work the morning
and then I could work a little bit on the plane and then guys, I got here, the room
wasn't ready of course, it was like 12, I hadn't slept much at all, I was so tired
but basically what I did is on Friday, I planned my day Friday like I was going to run the
whole day and then I said to myself, whatever I miss, whatever I don't get on Friday when
I'm traveling, I'm going to move it to Saturday and I'm going to take care of it and it sounds
like a great idea until it's actually Saturday and you actually have to do it and you actually
have to work and you're tired and your room's not ready but needless to say guys, Saturday
before I took a nap, before I did anything, I got here, I went to a coffee shop, I busted
out a couple hours of work, got some food, finally got checked in the room, did another
30 minutes of work and then I finally let myself sleep, okay.
I woke up before I went out, did anything, I went to the gym, these little teeny, these
little things guys, they are all adding up and it's crazy because they're all contributing
to like I've never, I feel momentum like I haven't in years, okay, again, this all comes
back to one thing, reading 10 pages of The Slide Edge every single day for the month
of February and it's completely transformed my entire business, I feel so much momentum,
I feel excited, I'm pumped, so I want to, I'm giving you guys a gift, there's a PDF,
type in Slide Edge PDF, it's completely free, you guys read 10 pages, they will change your
life, okay.
All right, that's it guys, that's all I want to share, let me turn the AC off, it's blowing
right on me, hold on.
And let's get into it guys, one quick thing, if you guys haven't already, please go and
update the map, I think I showed you guys last week, but let me, if I could just show
you really quick here, got a couple things I just want to show, well, let me go like
this, yeah, let me do this, I want to show you guys, because I think it's, I've said
this before, I'm going to see who's actually in town, where I'm at right now, let me get
my 7,000 windows closed up here, good night, hold on, sorry about that guys, okay, let
me go ahead and share my screen, really quick, go to the community here, all right, okay,
let's go like this, there we go, I think hopefully you guys can see my screen, all right, okay,
can you guys see my screen by the way, can you let me know in the chat, can anybody see
my screen, just can somebody confirm that, I think you can, right, my zoom's been really
weird lately, yes, okay, cool, yeah, so guys, really quick, let me just show you this super
quick, all you got to do is go like this, go to the classroom, come down here, hit community
world map, and then you're going to just click on this link here, and what you'll do is this
little button in the corner, this purple button, you'll click this, okay, and let me move this
really quick, it's going to say right here, add location, you take your ID, your school
ID, so for me, if I go to my thing here, my profile, I have this school ID right here,
I click on this, I go here, my display name, Nicholas Wood, and then my location, I'm going
to be, I'm in London right now, so I'm going to put London, UK, and boom, looks like me,
oh, here we go, I'm in London, and then Mr. Simon Tasker is also in London, okay, so guys,
go do that, it takes two seconds, it's just really cool to see where people are, who's
over here, somebody in Bulgaria, I think I saw that one last time, okay, great, and then
we've got somebody in India, so guys, take two seconds, go and just update this, I know
some of you guys have, but you have to actually go in and hit this button, and add your location,
if you don't do that, it's not going to work, okay, all right, I think that's it, I think
we can get into the good stuff, let me just double check here, okay, okay, yeah, there
is one more thing I want to cover, I think I mentioned this, or I did mention this, I
don't know if I did on this call, but I made a post, guys, I am working on a new, I'm actually,
the truth is, so I've been working on a new course for this community, and then we're
calling it the step-by-step guide to landing your first thousand dollar per month deal,
it's going to be literally breaking it down by week of what tasks you should do, it's
going to be very in-depth, very exact of what you should do to get that first deal, okay,
I'm really excited about it, I put in a lot of hours already, and all that I really have
left to do is the actual filming, so the hard stuff of writing the script of what I want
to put in it, the outline, what kind of resources, what kind of maps do I want to create, what
kind of, you know, all this different stuff, that part's just about done, I actually worked
on it this morning for about an hour, I made a post that said we're going to be dropping
a new course, I thought this was going to be really easy to create, and then I decided
that what I want to do, guys, and what I'm going to do is I'm actually going to, I'm
going to be changing the way that this entire community is consumed in all the content,
because right now we have a bunch of really good content, we have 15 mini courses, we
have so much stuff, and yes, I told you guys to start in the left and go to the right and
go like this, but I need to get even, I think I need to get even more specific of telling
you exactly what I think you should do on week one, day one, week two, week three, week
four, so I'm actually completely reorganizing everything, nothing that's in there's going
to be lost, I'm reorganizing everything in the way that it's consumed, I'm super pumped
about it, but I just want to give you guys an update, I said that was going to be done
in March, it is going to be done in March, but you got to give me probably this weekend,
next week, I'm going to have it, try to have it done by mid-March, this week, I'm in Paris,
I fly to Sierra Leone on Sunday, and then I'll spend the first week in Sierra Leone
filming it and have that thing live, so that is going to literally be live this month,
so if you guys saw that post, that's an update on that, so you guys have an idea, okay?
And then the last thing, I keep saying the last thing, but I just want these little tiny
updates, inside of every time we get done with these lives, these Q&A's, you can go
in like an hour after and we're going to have the replay inside of the replays mini course,
and we actually, I said I was going to do this last time, so we went in, and now what
we'll do is we break down all the different questions that are covered and time stamp
each question, so you can go through and literally just click on the video, fast forward to the
question you want answered, listen to your answer, and go move on and get to work, okay?
All the replays from when we started, I think there's like six, seven weeks worth now, you
guys can go check those out if you missed one, you can go look at the questions that
were covered, boom, scroll to that, and go and consume it really quick, and you guys
are done, okay?
So guys, let's get into it, what questions do you guys have for me on the business, on
anything related?
I'll give you guys an update on my agency here in a second, but let me see what questions
you guys have.
By the way, well, let me go start at the top here, okay, Craig said, goal setting for me
is the easy part, translating into data execution seems to be the gap in moving the needle,
lead lag activities, suggestions in changing that, so Craig, answer this in the comments
for me, is do you not know which daily activities you should execute, or are you just having
a hard time actually doing the thing?
Give me that clarification, we'll keep moving along with that thread, okay?
Okay, Paul says, are the videos you guys were putting together for Rare available yet?
Great question, that's something that Ryan's taken care of, let me message him right now
and ask, I know you asked a question about Rare last time, Paul, and I appreciate it,
and if you didn't get the answer, you should have, you asked me where does the data come
from, for the backlinking, the backlinking data, and it comes directly from Majestic,
which is like a really, really great tool for, the only problem is it only does backlinks,
that's it, but the data comes directly from Majestic, okay?
So let me ask Ryan really quick, I'm just gonna send him a quick text, okay, I will
have an answer for you, Paul, as soon as possible, there's Porter joining right now, okay, Francesco
says, how would you structure a Google Ads account and how would you organize keyword
ad groups, one group for a concrete contractors on or multiple services?
Okay, so I think it was you, Francesco, I think, I'm pretty sure I made a comment on
your post, you asked, I think you asked a part of this question, or maybe it was a bigger
part of this question, so I'm gonna give a little bit of guidance here, but I want you
to understand that I want you to be, I want everybody to be very careful with Google Ads,
okay, you need to understand that yes, Google Ads is a great part of the puzzle, it allows
you to move faster, it allows you to go and put up a one-pager today, run Google Ads,
get the things sped up and hopefully get a deal, at the same time, you have to remember,
I have spent $1.5 million, I have been doing Google Ads since 2020, I have lost a lot of
money and this is not even including the amount of money, guys, in the last year, I've spent
probably close to another 10 grand just on, listen to this, I've spent close to, maybe,
no, it's probably more than that, let's say about 10 grand, just in the last year, because
I was like, you know what, I think we can make our Google Ads training just a little
bit better, I'm talking about Inside Digital Landlords, I went, I found this guy that was
supposed to be really good, highly recommended and said, hey, give me a proposal, I want
to work with you, I want you to show me what you can do, I'm gonna let you run my campaigns,
I'm gonna pay you to run my campaigns and this individual ran my campaigns for months
and, long story short, they weren't really performing any better than what we were already
doing and I was paying a lot more money and it was a lot more difficult to set up and
all this stuff, so I spent $10,000 and all that I learned was that that guy didn't have
anything that I didn't already have, okay, so I'm telling you this because sometimes
we get in, we hear about running ads and we just think we're gonna throw up an ad and
leads are gonna come in, or I'm gonna give you one little answer and it's gonna change,
just understand that you either have to pay the $1.5 million to learn it or you need to
get proper training, which is what we do inside of Digital Landlords for Google Ads and I
want to say that because there's no way I could cover, now, why don't I cover more Google
Ads inside of the RankinRant Academy, well, the reason why is because I don't want this
to turn into a customer service nightmare, okay, once you commit to actually doing this
business for real, for real, for real and you're inside Digital Landlords, I know that
you're gonna do the business, I know that you have to make it work because you've committed
with your money, with your time, you've signed on a piece of paper, hey, I'm gonna do this
and so now let's do it, okay, but for me to come in and teach ads to people that a lot
of you guys or a lot of people inside of our community, a lot of them are just checking
this out, seeing if it's what they want to do, it's literally just gonna turn into a
customer service nightmare, so it's just not economical, it doesn't make any sense for
me to talk at length, okay, but back to your question really, really quick, so how would
you structure a Google Ads account and how would you organize keyword ad groups, one
group for keyword contractors, example, multiple services, so again, I try to keep things really
simple, okay, with our Google Ads, what I try to do just to be very transparent is I
try to like literally set up the most basic ads as possible and start tweaking, start
learning for years, I didn't even run negative keywords, I still don't like do a lot of that
stuff, I know, you know, Jeff is, we have a guy inside digital landlords that is kind
of our, he's our ad specialist, he does office hours, for those of you that are in digital
landlords by the way, Paul and you guys, what we've done is over the last week, we've taken
all the live, the office hours that Jeff's done, and we've kind of organized them into a
folder and we're going to start putting them inside of the training inside digital landlords,
you guys will be able to go and check through those, but you know, some of the things that
he'll say is like, you know, you can set the ads to start running at 7am and stop running
at 7pm, I don't even mess with that stuff, okay, you can, I don't think it's bad, what my only
advice I'm going to give you is to just simplify it, with this specific example,
there's no way that we could go into that and not confuse a bunch of people,
if you want to message me privately, then I can maybe point you in the right direction with some
resources, but we just don't cover a lot of the ad stuff, especially like those nuanced questions,
because there's more, you need more context, there's more to it than just, you know,
what is the budget? Well, and I know that's not what you're asking, but if somebody asks,
what should you set the daily budget at? Well, it really depends, you know, should I let it go
higher than five bucks per cost per click? Well, what are you, what factors are we, what's, what,
you know, what niche are we looking at? What city, what kind of budget, what kind of a deal are you
looking to sign? How much budget are you going to have? You know, how, like there's so many
different factors, so if you want, you can message me privately on school, I'll see what I can
do to, in terms of pointing you in the right direction, but that's the stuff that we cover
more into the more in-depth training, okay? Okay, let's keep going. Craig says, I think I just
answered my question clearly defined why. Okay, he's talking about executing. Sorry,
I'm jumping ahead here. Okay. What's that? Craig, let's go up to Michael says, how do you
overcome the objection of track record or past successes when closing the first deal,
not having an example testimonies? Porter, are you still on this Porter? If you are, dude, hop on.
Let me ask you to unmute. I'm going to help you have you answer this question because this is
something you just barely dealt with. Let me see if Porter's on right now. If Porter is, I'm going
to have him all answered. If not, oh, there he is. Porter, can you hear me? Yeah, I can hear you.
Beautiful. I want you to answer this question for Michael, just because this is something
you're currently dealing with, but he says, how do you overcome the objection of track records?
You get on a call with the business owner. It's your first deal. They don't have any other proof,
you don't have any other websites to show anybody of, hey, I did this for so-and-so.
How do you deal with that at the business owners asking you for references or whatever? How did
you get your first deal that way? When I have anything, I honestly was just super transparent.
I wasn't like, you're my first deal, but in a way I was like, I want to build this relationship
off trust. I understand you probably want proof and all this, but I've sent you three or four
leads. You've quoted them. I'm getting the jobs. I want to build this out of trust. If you have any
second thoughts now, then I would rather you tell me, then we get into this some months.
I almost just play that card because, again, I don't want to lie to the guy, but again,
you want to work with someone that's not always questioning you. If he's questioning you, it's
most likely you've maybe done something in the past. You haven't quite earned their trust enough
for them not to, because when I did it right the first time, no one asked me about it, but I've
been asked that when I haven't gained enough trust before the call. Does that make sense?
Yeah, it's true. This is one of the things to remember, Michael, is if you are getting the
same objection again and again and again, it's usually something that at a subconscious level
you have an issue with. For example, people that I always hear are like, how do you get around price?
How do you get around price? Dude, I never get objection of price. I think one of the reasons
why is because to me, if you tell me, hey, it's a thousand bucks a month, that is not to me personally
because I've been in business. I know what stuff costs. I know what it costs to pay for employees,
to pay for an office. A thousand bucks a month is just another bill,
right? But sometimes when we start business and we're used to a $4,000 a month salary
and every hundred dollars counts, and I've been there and we're asking people for a thousand bucks
a month, and you know that if somebody asks you for a thousand bucks a month, it would scare the
crap out of you. What you're doing is you're selling out of your own wallet, and so you're
projecting whatever. I never get price. I never get price objection. I never get contract objection.
Why? Because I've resolved these objections in myself, and I've seen this with sales reps.
I've seen this with people that I've trained in all kinds of different areas. If you are continually
getting that, I don't know if you are, but if Michael, if you're getting this again and again,
you have to realize that you're probably somebody, I'm guessing, that has to see a track record or
whatever, but I like what Porter said, and I think it's really true, is you just be transparent. You
probably don't go in like Porter's saying and be like, yeah, this is my very first client ever.
Congratulations. However, I think it's fine to just be very transparent and be like, hey,
I'm actually pretty new to this, but look, I've already sent you three leads. The proof's in the
pudding, and I'd love to earn your business, and you can even frame it like you're giving them a
bit of a deal as long as they give a testimony like, hey, I'm normally going to charge $1,500
for this. I'm only going to charge you $1,000 if you'll give me a testimony once this is said
and done. That's one way. Another thing that you can do is you can borrow off of other people's
success. I'm more than happy if you guys want to use one of my websites, like Bentonville Concrete,
and show them, hey, this is one of our partner sites, blah, blah, blah. Can you come back in
20 minutes? Hold on. Porter, keep going. Yeah. No, and that's a good point. For my first deal,
I actually used Bentonville Concrete as a site that would say, hey, this is the goal. Obviously,
I don't have one that I've ranked organically myself because I'm pre-sold by pre-selling,
but I have used Bentonville Arkansas to close my first deal. Again, if they're wanting like, hey,
do you have other reviews of a website for your company? It's like, no, I don't have a website.
I don't have any other clients. You're my first client, but you don't say that. Yeah,
I think it's totally chill. Up until just recently, I started using my own sites,
but I was using Bentonville Arkansas for my first five deals.
It's not a big deal if you guys want to do that. Guys, when I first started knocking doors,
you know what they trained me on? They said the same thing. They're like, well,
when you knock on the door, you want to name drop a couple of people you've started working,
you've done deals for, and I'm like, well, this is my first deal. They're like, well,
I just closed this lady named Susie, and there's this other guy named Danny, so you're going to
use those names, and they gave me their last names, whatever. So I'd knock on the door,
keep in mind I'm in Arkansas, and I'm like, hey, you happen to know Lucy down the street,
or I can't remember if it was, anyway. I'm like, do you know so-and-so? I've used the full name,
Lucy Smith. Oh, you don't know Lucy? Meanwhile, she's in Utah, right? They're customers,
but I'm like, yeah, we just set them up, which we did. They're just in Utah.
We kind of just leveraged that confidence. Anyway, you could do it any way you want to do.
You don't have to be shady or anything like that, but just be transparent. It's the same
thing when people always ask me, what do you do when the business owner asks you
how you're getting the leads? I'm like, you tell them? You tell them. What do you mean?
Well, you want to show them the website? Yeah. What if they ask you if you're running ads?
Yeah. What's there to hide? Yeah, I'm running ads, dude. I'm getting you leads. You got a
problem with that? It doesn't matter. Same thing, but it's a bit nerve-racking when you
don't have your first deal. Just use Bentonville Concrete. Use any of my websites. Be transparent
with them. Again, coming back to what Porter said, if you give leads up front, that's going
to overcome most of the objections. That's going to help eliminate the biggest objection,
which is the trust issue. That's what you're dealing with is the person doesn't totally
trust you yet because they're asking for reviews. I would say to them, Mr. Business
Owner, what do you need to see? My leads is my credentials. You're getting leads. What
else do you need to know? You know what I'm saying? Usually they don't care. Even if you
ranked organically and you're getting them leads and they're not making money, they're going to
stop working with you regardless. Or you could be paying for Google Ads and be sending them the
same leads and they could be making money on them. They don't care where they're coming from. As
long as they're making money, they're not going to ask questions. Very true. Very true.
Let's see. This is a good question here. I want to address it.
Craig was talking about, he's like goal setting is the easy part. Then he's like,
how do you translate it into daily execution? I asked him, I said, is your problem with
figuring out what to do or actually executing on it? He said that he answered his own question.
He said executing. Then a little bit later, he said, I think I just answered my own question,
clearly defining why. Porter, let me ask you about this. You've been doing this about two years.
You've probably had times where, because you've set your goals, you know exactly what you need
to do. This week, I need to hook two business owners, whatever. Let's say that's your activities.
How have you been able to get more consistent with actually executing on the things
that you need to do? What would you say your advice is? Because I know that there's been
times when you've kind of sloughed off or gotten distracted. Then recently, this year,
if you guys weren't inside of digital landlords, me and Porter, was it last week? I think so. Maybe
last week we talked about replacing business owners. Porter actually lost two business
owners in the same day and replaced them the same day. Then he also hooked somebody else. Then
he had them on trial. Porter gets a lot more nos than he talks about. He's got somebody else
on trial. Anyway, how have you been able to stay consistent with executing the actual activities?
Hey, I need to hook a business owner every week. In order to do that, I need to call
five business owners. Not call, but talk to five business owners. How do you get yourself to
consistently do that? It's easy to put it down. It's hard to actually do. What are some tips?
I think the first thing is to share your goals with somebody else, whether it's the group or
someone that you feel like is actually going to hold you accountable. I think as soon as I told
people within the group that I was making 10K, the last thing I want to do is to either get on a call
and not be at 10K when we're talking about making money at 10K. My standard was, oh, I'm just kind
of below 10K to now. I've hit the 10K and my pride is I don't want to get below that. It's crazy
what your mind and what you can accomplish when you are like, hey, I'm just not dropping below
this. Me and Nick talked about this before, but it's like a thermostat. As soon as the temperature
drops below a certain point, the AC unit or the heater kicks on and then it gets to a certain
point. Then we get comfortable and then it kicks off. I think that was my biggest thing is I'm
still trying to figure this out, but I want to consistently be going this way and not just feel
like this comfort. I just think for me, it's like share your goals with people and set your
standards of this is just who I am. This is what I do because I think that's the hardest thing is
I was doing this consistently, but was I actually bought into it? Was I actually doing it to make
money or was I doing it to say, hey, I was just doing this business model every day? I wasn't
really moving the needle. Like last week, I had this guy that I had hooked that Nick was talking
about. Basically, we didn't make it to the call and I immediately got back on the phone and I
called someone and I have a Zoom call scheduled for Saturday, which they had to push it today,
so I rescheduled it. It's at 430 today. Before that, I felt like it would have really discouraged
me because I would have lost that deal technically, but then it's like I could
have waited a week to call somebody else, but you just get back on the phone and you're like,
I want to get past that 10K. I don't want to be just barely over 10K. That's just my standard now.
That's probably the best way that I can explain it now. I'm still working on it. I'm not perfect,
but that's just kind of what has really driven me recently.
Good. Yeah. I mean, at the end of the day,
it's like, and I think you answered your own question. He said clearly defining his why.
It's like when I wake up tired and not excited about stuff, I'll be honest, this morning I woke
up. I'm still a little jet lagged. I don't know why, but I woke up and I woke up at 630.
I did my regular stuff. The first hour, I wasn't jacked about sitting down,
planning out all my employees' to-do lists, and then planning my team meeting.
I have the same Monday pretty much every single Monday. I wasn't super thrilled about it,
and I didn't feel that great either, just for the record. But I know, and I remember thinking
there are certain things that I want to do this year that's going to require a certain amount
of capital. There's been some investments that I really, really want to make that's going to put
me in a position to be very, very set in terms of passive income. And in order for me to be part
of these projects, I'm going to need to bring a lot of money to the table. Because I know exactly
what I want to do, where I'm going to put that money, how much money I need to bring in,
when I start getting tired, I'm like, dude, Nick, just pull out of it for a second, go walk around
the block, whatever, do some press ups, drink some water, get back to it. It's all going to
be worth it in the end. So yes, defining your why and exactly why you're doing this. And then
also just think about the alternative. If that doesn't inspire you, if you don't have a why that
inspires you, think about the alternative. Think about what life is going to look like if you keep
on the same path that you're on right now. Just like, let's say we even were Porter's at. Porter's
making 10K a month. That's great. He's in a much better position than he was making $0 per month
and just making money from his full-time thing. But if he stays the same, he's going to just be
at 10K per month in five years. That's not exciting. That's terrible. So I always think about,
if you know exactly what you want, why you want it, but then also just look at what's the
alternative. For me, I'm so terrified of waking up and realizing I just wasted it.
And not only I just wasted it, but I was just another average freaking dude that's like,
yeah, he was a good guy and he was a hard worker. And it's like, so? Everybody's a good guy and a
hard worker. I want to be somebody that actually did something huge and did something that changed
a lot of lives. And I'm so terrified of just blending into everybody else. And so these things
drive me. And sometimes I'm using negative things to drive me. Sometimes it's positive things. But
I guess the quote is, I don't know the exact quote, but
you do what needs to be done when it needs to be done, regardless of how you feel. That's it.
You map it out. You set the goal. You map it out. And then you do
what has to be done that day. And guys, you're most of the time not going to feel like doing it.
That's just the truth. When I got here on Saturday, I think I was sharing this at the beginning,
Porter, you missed it. But when I got here on Saturday, I had things that I missed on Friday
because I was traveling. And I told myself, if I'm going to miss those things, it's about three
hours worth of work. I'm either doing it on the plane or I'm doing it when I get to the hotel
before I do anything. And I was so tired. I had not slept crap. I got like 30 minutes to an hour
done on the plane, got here before I slept because the room wasn't that I cranked out the work.
And I wasn't inspired by it. I was tired. I was just like some of it. I was quite honestly
going through the motions, but I had to get certain things done. And every part of me wanted to,
I'll just do it on Monday. I'll push it till next week. I'm like, no, I've committed to doing this.
And then I woke up from my nap and I'm like, Hey, I got to go to the gym. And I didn't want to go to
the gym because I was supposed to go out at, you know, meet my friend at a certain time for this
event. But I'm like, dude, I've already committed to doing it. I've got certain fitness goals that
I've got to hit. And that's it. So get clear about your wild, think about the alternative,
and then just do it. It's just a habit of doing it, even if you don't feel like doing it, I think.
And it's, and it's also comes down to like, when you say you're going to do something like the night
before, it's like, you're so motivated to do something. And then the next day, it's like,
you don't feel like it. But if you keep telling, like, if you don't, if, like, if you don't do what
you tell yourself, you're going to do it. Like your confidence just goes down. It's so easier to like,
say, Oh, I didn't do that. Like, I'm not going to do that either. Or like, I'm not going to eat
better. Or like, I'm not going to work out. Like, if I didn't work out, I'm not going to eat good.
You know what I'm saying? It's like, every time that you tell yourself you're going to do something,
don't do it. It's like, you're shooting yourself in the foot. Like, you got to fall through with
what you're going to say you're going to do. And when you do that, it's like a domino effect.
It's like, you just want to keep checking things off your list and you feel really good about
yourself. These guys got, I told these guys at the beginning, they got out of read the slide edge,
dude. Dude, it's crazy guys. What, what, what, what, how, how far in are you?
I, I passed the part where, uh, the, the penny and the, the million dollars.
So are you, what percentage are you? Uh, 20, 25%. Nice. Phenomenal book guys. Um, I told you,
you can go type in slide edge PDF. You can get it for free at that. You could also go pay seven
bucks on Kindle or you could buy the, the, uh, the soft copy. I have all, I've read the book five
times. Um, it's a very simple book, but basically it just talks about this doing simple stuff.
And I'm telling you guys, and I said this before I even read this book this year,
I'd read the book in the past. My, my theme of 20, 25 is simplify and eliminate, right?
Get simple, eliminate the crap that doesn't matter. Okay. Get rid of all the extra fluff
and the meetings and the, this, that, and the rest and just focus on my core business
and growing it and being very simple and just doing it again and again and being really good at
it. And then I started reading this book and it just talks about, again, simplicity,
doing the little simple things every single day. And I promise you, they add up. So guys,
just one more plug, go check out this book. It's not my, not my, not my, I'm not getting
the commission on it, but it's a great book. Okay. Kevin Williams says business owner misses
the zoom call. What do you do? Porter, you've had this happen. Yeah, that's, that's a hard
conversation, especially when you think that they're solid. I mean, I would just message them,
say, Hey, Mr. Business owner. Like I, I see that you missed our call at such and such time. Like,
you know, I was really looking forward to chatting with you, but it seems like you're either,
you know, have enough work or maybe something came up. Like, please let me know so that we
can either reschedule or, you know, I just don't want to waste your time. So I think giving them
a little pullback, I mean, stuff does happen, like stuff emergencies do happen, but like very
rarely does it actually happen. Sometimes it's just, they're just blowing smoke, but you try to
give them the benefit of the doubt. Maybe they just need more time to think about it. But that's
what I like. This, this guy, he literally missed my zoom call and he was like, I'm out on the job
and I was like, well, dude, I got, I'm partnered with someone today because I did have another,
like I didn't have them scheduled, but I was like, I got to schedule with someone. I'd rather sit,
tell you, have you tell me no than for me to just be, you know, just waiting on the zoom call day.
So I sent him a message and then he basically fired back and was like, Hey, I watched your video.
Like, I only want to do a paper lead model and whatever. So I was like, you know what? It's,
it's totally fine. Like, thanks for the conversation. We'll, we'll, we'll revisit this
later. So anyways, left it to that hook somebody else. But that's what I would say. Just have a,
have a conversation with them. I always try not to come out guns a blaze in the first text,
but like at the same time, you got to lay it across like, Hey, I'm looking to partner with
someone, whoever I partner with first, I'm going to go with. So if you want this, like let's
reschedule this for later today or, you know, really soon. Yeah. I think too guys, you need to
what's, what, how do I say this? Whatever you tolerate is what, what people will do to you,
right? It's, it's what you're going to receive. If I've sent you three leads
and I know you've quoted them, right. And you don't get on that call, dude, I'm, I'm pissed
and I'm not, I'm going to be a little more tactful than maybe what I'm saying right now, but
I'm, I'm not going to be super happy. I do this too. Like I've, like this happened about a week
and a half ago. This happens when with business owners happens with people that try to buy our
program. I think this, this was, I think again, about 10 days ago, we had this guy that whatever
he, he applied and then he traveled and whatever. And I, I told him, I said, I'm going to be on the
call just to say, hi, I want to meet you. And I literally had like planned my day. There was like
three, four calls that day that we had to do, but I shifted my calendar so I could be on the call.
And the guy, my team was like, yeah, he canceled. And I was like, give me this guy's number.
And I text him and I was like, Hey, this is Nick. I said, you missed the meeting. I don't, I'm not
sure why. And he's like, yeah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. Gave me some reason. I said, look,
I said, I've, I literally, I moved my day around to be on this call. I said, the least you could
have done is like jumped on the call and give me an explanation, right? No pressure, but like,
that's not cool. That's how you do business. And the guy's like, yeah, you're right. Blah, blah,
blah. I just don't tolerate that. And so if somebody misses a meeting, it's, it's usually
indicative of how they're going to do business in the future. I'm not super interested in working
with people that can't get on a meeting. So, and I'll tell them that like, Hey, I've got other
people to work with. You're, your, your money spends the same money as freaking Susan's down
the street. And I'm like, I'm moving on. And guys, if you've sent them three leads, that's
going to sting a little bit. They're going to be like, Oh, I'm super sorry. Let me hop on.
Remember they need us more than we need them. Okay. Don't forget that.
Okay. Paul says, fake it till you make it. He says, kidding using the community sites
is legit. Oops. Being that you are using the same tactics and part of a network. He's talking about
using other people's sites. It's kind of for that first deal, by the way, if you are in digital
landlords, we have a thread in there. If you search for it with a bunch of people that have
listed their website and the name of the business owner and the deals, the deal size where you can
name drop some of these first deals to get your first day, you can name drop some of these other
deals. Okay. And that's true. That's part of the community that we should be leveraging. Okay.
Michael says, makes sense. That's, it's coming from my own personal issues of the consumer
needing proof, talking about his objection that he's getting about what needing, needing a reference
or seeing case studies or whatever. If you're sending leads, they shouldn't need it. That's the
fact. It's Kevin, the solid advice. Okay. Titus says, how can I find a business owner's name in
public records? The internet's wild guys. There's so many ways. If you just do some digging,
I will tell you that like we give specific strategies and techniques. I'm not sure if
Titus is inside digital lands. If you're in digital landlords and you go into module two, building
your list, we walk you through exact tactics. Okay. But if you're not, then some things that
I would recommend is here's a little hack. Go to Google, the Google listing or the Facebook listing
and look at the reviews and start reading through the reviews. A lot of times in the reviews,
these small businesses, the business owner's name will be mentioned in the reviews, right?
The person will be like, we had a phenomenal time with Carlos was really great. He was really
professional. And then the next one's like, awesome job. Had a good exchange with Carlos. I see Carlos
like three, four times, right? So then I start going, okay, Carlos. So I type in the business
owner's name plus Carlos. And all of a sudden, there pops his name. Now I got his name. Then
I'm into Facebook. I'm looking at what he's into, blah, blah, blah. And I'm down the wormhole.
That's just one way of finding the business owner's name. But guys, there's so many tools out there.
You have freaking, I mean, with AI, unbelievable. By the way, I just barely got done. My buddy works
at Google. He's on one of the, he's on the AI, one of the AI teams at Google here in London.
And the kind of money that Google is putting into AI right now is mind-bending. It is freaking
mind-bending because ChatGPT is posing a real threat to Google's main product, which is Google
Ads. I don't know if you guys knew this, but Google Ads, and I literally just confirmed this
with him. He's like, their main revenue stream is Google Ads, okay? So anything that's a threat to
Google Ads, they're going to try and protect. And so ChatGPT, where people are going in and asking
ChatGPT questions, it's pulling away from people searching in Google. So that's why they came out
with Gemini. Anyway, they're putting in a ridiculous amount of money into AI. Go and use these tools,
these AI tools. And I bet you, you're going to be able to find business owner's names really easy.
Okay. Just a little tip there. Okay. Paul says Botzel is a great scraping software that takes
all the business owners in the area and puts them in a spreadsheet. It leverages GMBs. That's great.
Great little, I didn't know, I've never heard of that tool. Sounds awesome. Tidus said,
awesome. Appreciate it guys. Beautiful. Porter, your deal's at 430 today.
Yep. Got one at 430.
How much are you pitching it for?
I'm pitching it for 1500. This is going to be a different call. The owner is actually a woman,
which isn't a bad thing. I've just never quoted or pitched a woman yet as a fencing business owner.
It's a different sell. It's a softer sell. I will say you need to make sure your objections
are overcome upfront. Because as soon as you get to objection overcoming and you start trying to
do your techniques, your tie-downs and stuff, they're very quickly like, no, I don't want to
do it. Just as in door-to-door sales, whatever. I will tell you, we've worked with business
owners in the past that are women. We have one right now that's a client that is a woman. Great
business. Been working with them. I think they're in Colorado. I think I snuck one in the springs,
but not going to tell you about it. My hometown, dude.
Porter gets this deal. That's going to put Porter at $1,200 per month. For those of you that are
just starting, Porter, two and a half years ago, Porter didn't know how to run Google ads. He
didn't know how to build a website. He didn't know anything about SEO. He didn't even know how
to get on Zoom, nor did I. Literally. Yeah. Actually, we're still having problems with Zoom.
If you're struggling getting your first deal, you're over-complicating the process.
Literally just the other day, Porter, when he was telling me about this deal,
I asked him, I said, hey, is this somebody that got an existing website? Is this whatever he's
pre-selling? He's like, I'm just following the training. I'm like, yeah, go figure.
You get your first deal sometimes, guys, and you just think you're smarter than the process. The
process is the process for a reason. The process works. I use this example in the training.
It's like a perfect recipe for baking a cake. Sometimes we build a cake or we bake a cake,
aka we get a deal, and we think, hey, instead of adding the flour here, I'm going to wait until
it's mixed, and then after the milk, I'm going to put the flour in. You forget that there's a reason
why you put the flour in before you do the milk or whatever the case is. There's a reason why
I made the recipe exactly like I made the recipe is because it freaking works. If you don't think
I've tried putting in the chocolate chips at the beginning, then you're crazy because I've tried
all the different combinations, and I'm constantly trying to figure out, hey,
how can we make the same cake in a shorter period of time? How can we make the same cake
with cheaper ingredients? That's why I spent 10,000 bucks on Google Ads from a guy who it
didn't even work. It didn't even help me, but I had to know, hey, can we improve in this area?
Didn't work, spent 10 grand, but that's the value you guys get from being inside the community.
So anyway, Porter, by the way, we also are pitching a deal today. I'm not doing it.
Francesca's doing it. It's not going to be huge. I think it's going to be probably between 500
and 1,000 bucks a month for excavation. I'm not sure I would recommend the niche. We had a referral.
We built it a few years ago, and the guy only had one piece of equipment, and I don't remember
exactly how we lost. We ended up only keeping it for three to six months. Websites have been
sitting there. It's pumping out a few leads. So me and Francesca were getting scrappy. We were like,
dude, we've got to sell some of these websites that are not making money. So we started doing
some Facebook little techniques, and sure enough, dude, we already sent a lead over on the weekend,
guys coming in to meet with Francesca in person, and then she's going to send a screencast. So
we're going for an excavation deal, and then we're going for another deal that I can't tell
you guys the niche because I want to make sure it works, but it could be a very lucrative niche
that you guys have not thought of. So that's the plan. And by the way, I'm not doing any of these
deals myself. This is just me advising Francesca. So hopefully we snag at least one of these deals
this week. So anyway, I can't remember who said they were in. Was it Francesca who said he's in
UK? Let me double check. Francesca, if you're the one that's in the UK, dude, hit me up. I'm here for
another day or two. Let me just see if I can find that. I think it was him.
Yeah, he's in the UK. Beautiful. Yeah, shoot me a message on school. We'll talk about Google Ads.
I'm here. Maybe if I have time, we can meet up for coffee or something. But I am in London for
the next day and a half and I'm going to Paris. So anyway, guys, one last thing real quick.
Starting next week, I'm going to be doing these Q&As slightly different. I'm either going to have
a theme, a Q&A theme. So I'll say, hey, this is all sales Q&A, or I'm going to do a little bit of a
training with a specific topic for the first half and then we can ask questions going off of that.
OK, so you can come with any questions that you want, but I'm going to try to send out a reminder
email Sunday night to remind you guys that, hey, Monday morning, we're going to be doing the live
get on it. And this is the topic that we're going to be training on. Then you guys can jump on and
we can go over that specific topic. So anyway, guys, that said, happy Monday, happy March. Go
over your goals. Review what happened in February. If you fell short, make your course corrections.
And we got one more month and quarter one is done. And then we got three quarters left in the game,
baby. That's it. So anyway, thanks for jumping on Porter. See you guys. Yep. We'll see you guys.